For many years, you have been the Chancellor
of the Pontifical Academy of Social Sciences.
Why do you take the Social Sciences as part
of the Vatican, and what is your ambition
with this academy, which became famous to
the world when, not that long ago, you invited
Bernie Sanders to be one of your guests to
speak about ecology?
The new Academy of Social Sciences, created in 1994, worked very well, especially  in a theoretical way.
It studied the problem of globalization, it
studied the problem of war.
It studied the problem of religion and the
new sciences and many very interesting things.
But it was more theoretical.
When Francis became Pope, he asked the Academy,
he asked me: please study the problem of the
new forms of slavery, of human trafficking
and the trafficking of organs, of organized
crime, the question of narcotics - very complicated
things.
We accepted this challenge, and we studied
these important subjects for the past three
years.
We organized many meetings.
Now, we understand many things.
The first thing is that it is very important
that the religions work together in defense
of human dignity and freedom, especially against
these new forms of slaves, of which today
there are 40 million.
The pope came here, we invited the most important
religious leaders, and the message was: these
new forms of slavery are a crime against humanity.
We need to work together, we can pray together,
because even if there are different ideas
about God, God is only one.
Anyway, we can - and need to - work and act
together to defend human dignity.